questions surround the death of a
newborn baby who died in foster care now
the i-team has uncovered a document
which reveals the foster parents were
previously investigated for neglect in
an unrelated case more than two years
ago now in this exclusive interview the
child's grandmother is looking for
answers as vanessa murphy reports this
isn't the first tragedy for the family
this year
this is eci joelle the only thing that
you want is justice this is eci's
grandmother she's asked the eye team to
protect her identity
last april her daughter was stabbed to
death in a parking lot right in front of
her metro police say the killer is her
ex-boyfriend she was a new mom to baby
ecie the grandmother says child
protective services or cps took custody
of the infant the same day she says she
expected they would soon be reunited and
in the meantime she prepared to
permanently care for him i need my
grandson back
because
i'm going to be ready
ok
to help him she says she repeatedly
reached out to a cps caseworker to ask
to be reunited with her grandson i am
ready
to get him
and ready
and i was very happy
okay
he never returned my messages she tells
the i-team she finally received a call
from the clark county coroner's office
he said no
i have bad news for you and he told me
that he's dead i screamed
i screamed
i was very mad she says no details about
the child's death were shared with her
the i-team dug for answers and found
that according to the coroner's office
at two months and 14 days old isi died
at university medical center after an
incident in the master bedroom of a
foster family assigned to care for him
that's 26 days after the grandmother
says cps took custody of him eci's cause
of death is pending we also obtained
this child fatality disclosure which
states the department of family services
received a report that the child had
been found unresponsive in his crib by
his foster parent it also states that
the same foster parents were previously
investigated a report was received
alleging neglect in 2018 for at least
one other child in their care the
allegations in that case were found
unsubstantiated our clients
need to
know what happened attorney andre lago
marcino is representing the family
although a lawsuit has not been filed
they need to proceed
with all the natural processes of
grieving and
getting answers the i-team reached out
to cps for answers in an email a
spokesman wrote that cps is awaiting the
coroner's report the foster parents have
not been charged their license is on
hold and under investigation and they
currently do not have any foster
children when we asked why cps isn't
sharing information with a grandmother
we were told that confidentiality
requirements preclude cps from sharing
information with her without parental
consent again the child's father is
charged with murder records show he's
currently going to be transferred to a
mental health facility and the child's
mother was killed as she grieves the
loss of her daughter the grandmother is
in disbelief about the loss of her
grandson in my heart
i think
she's not dead it's not easy it's very
hard i love him vanessa murphy 8 news
now
you heard vanessa talk there about
excuse me parental consent apparently
she followed up with three additional
emails asking cps about the
confidentiality regarding the child
since the mother is dead and according
to records the father has been declared
not competent for trial however no
additional response or explanation was
given